is this your car
it's not your car
oh whose car is it
now at six eight news now bringing you
police body cam video leading up to the
arrest of ex-nfl star marshawn lynch on
suspicion of dui
it's video you saw first inside the
eight news now app thank you for joining
us i'm brian loftis and i'm kirsten
joyce the i-team's david charns has more
of that footage and more on what's being
said david kirsten the video is
appearing to show marshawn lynch
sleeping in the driver's seat of what
police call a quote undrivable car and
you'll see why here as an officer walks
up to that car around 7 30 tuesday
morning the unregistered vehicle had no
rim or tire on the front driver's side
wheel at the bottom of your screen there
and police also say the rear driver's
side wheel was about to fall off you can
hear officers say they believe lynch was
driving around in loops in this area and
they think that because of scratches
that they say they found in the road
here's where an officer asks lynch who
owns the car and just who he is
is this your car
it's not your car
oh whose car is it
you know who you are
no you don't know who you are
okay
you heard there lynch sort of saying he
didn't know who he was officers say
lynch was uncooperative and would not
get out of the car and that led to this
driving the cars
what is the problem
i'm just asking what is the problem no
he
kind of gave us
[Music]
roll over can't find your back
no more games today
because i'm not moving it does smell
like alcohol apparently officers had had
enough there as attorneys richard
schoenfeld and david chesnov saying in a
statement quote marshawn was not pulled
over for a dui rather the vehicle was
safely parked and not in operation
police do say the car was not running
you can watch the entire arrest right
now on 8news.com lynch's court date is
not until december i'm david sharon 8
news now
david thank you sleeping it off in the
car can be a defense to a dui charge but
under nevada law all of these conditions
have to be met you can't be in the
driver's seat the engine of the car must
not be running also the car must be
legally parked and police will also make
sure the car was not driven to the
location it was found by the intoxicated
person